[Music]
for almost 75 years the Korean Peninsula
has been divided the two countries share
an ancient heritage culture but today
are still officially
the reason history of North and South
Korea is a story of conflict and
separation and his times has pushed the
world right to the very edge
[Music]
a NASA satellite photo taken in 2016
shows probably better than any other
single image the differing fortunes of
modern-day career to the South the
bright light shine out from one of the
planet's richest economies and most
advanced societies such contrast to the
darkness of the north a secretive
repressive and dilapidated state left
behind by the world around North Korea
has deliberately cultivated its image
over its short history the Kim family
has ruled this country for almost 75
years from grandfather to father to son
the dynasty has reigned uninterrupted
but it is not been without challenge if
we look at the history of the whole
Korean Peninsula since the late 19th
century has been one of turmoil almost
without cease for the first half of the
20th century the Korean Peninsula was a
single country occupied by the Japanese
[Music]
occupied by American forces their
surrender and eviction in 1945 is the
starting point for what we now know as
North and South Korea it wasn't that
South in North Korea's a fool decided to
split it
it was the Allies so US China Russia the
Americans they realized that the
Russians were in a position to occupy
Korea so they wanted to propose a
division line it for two zones of
occupation and in the mid of the nights
they sent a couple of officers into a
side room they decided suggests the 38th
parallel North Koreans believe that they
have been the victim of outside
aggressive Western history records it
very differently it was not Korea
invaded South Korea
train you could chew in two
it was the start of a vicious conflict
that would last three years and define
relations on the peninsula to this day
what did you know about Korea nothing at
all nothing at all
it was all new to me I try to look it up
but no map to see where it was exactly
and so on but you know it was just all
new to me
I wasn't really looking forward to going
to be honest Peter ty lee was 18 when he
was sent to Korea he didn't fight in the
Second World War far too young but
joined the Royal Fusiliers on national
service and my first reaction was it was
so primitive no nobility just sort of
them wooden hats dirt tracks for roads
and so on very very primitive they seem
to be short of food and everything there
you know they seem to be scavenging that
was my impression anyway in 1950 the
Chinese joined the conflict on the side
of the North Koreans the Americans under
a UN remit gave their support to the
south
the result was mass slaughter
the Fusiliers in fact I think lost a
total of 38 men how about you any of
your friends any of your home yes in
fact in one of the well as I turned up
with him in the Queen's Regiment at
Guildford he was one of the first killer
actually very sad day
it was very much a civilian war you know
more civilians died and soldiers in the
Korean War it was utterly devastating
the war swept up and down the peninsula
to two or three times South Korean
government divided to sign on the press
treaty
technically we are still during the war
for older generation like my parents or
even grandparents it was something that
it is still significant in their
lifetime as well as being physically
divided North and South Korea went down
to different political paths the South
chose free-market capitalism was Kim
il-sung allied the north with its
communist neighbors China and the Soviet
Union Makino song did adopt Stalin's
model you know nationalization of the
economy close control of society
surveillance of people at the beginning
if we compare at that moment North Korea
had a better economic status than South
Korea they are bordered with China and
Russia it was easier for them to have a
influence it's often said that by the
late 50s early 60s North Korea was the
second most industrialized country in
East Asia but it didn't last the Soviet
Union collapsed and North Korea who was
left exposed it just through North Korea
into
I would say we pretty much panic you
know and and that was that had very real
consequences for North Korea as well you
know it lost its source of subsidized
trade it lost its security umbrella the
economy collapsed by the early early to
mid-1990s compounded then by natural
disasters and famine and so on so it
created this
I think profound sense of sort of
psychological unease and insecurity from
the North Koreans what bank and I'm star
as North Korea was faltering South Korea
was transforming itself from poor
neighbor to become the 11th richest
country in the world is the home of
sampson island ID and the legendary kpop
[Music]
soul might only be 35 miles from the
border with North Korea and well within
range of Pyongyang's missiles
culturally economically politically it
is a world away
jinnie are in many ways in bodies this
modern cultural divide she is a
contemporary dancer a celebrity judge on
the Korean version of Dancing with the
Stars and she choreographed part of the
opening and closing ceremonies of the
recent Winter Olympics in South Korea an
event which was in many ways a coming of
age for the country and a rare example
of unity on the Korean Peninsula the
main message we tried to deliver through
the Olympics was peace passion and
harmony the most meaningful thing for us
and for the event was that the North and
South teams entered together in the
opening ceremony and also we had the
unified teams for several sports
I think this had a very positive
influence on relations between north and
south for the contemporary generation I
can say there's no border between
Western and Eastern or between the
Western world in the Korean world in
North Korea images and statues of Kim
il-sung and Kim jong-il are everywhere
they are worshipped as gods a besotted
personality cult that has been carefully
and brutally nurtured by the Kim family
it's more useful to think of North Korea
as a 19th century oriental despotism
that through a curious twist of fate the
survived into the 21st century
when I reported from North Korea this
personality cult was immediately
noticeable in everything we saw and were
told Kim jong-il died in 2011 it was a
moment of national power for the new
young and relatively unknown leader Kim
jong-un it was also a moment of
potential instability as he sought to
assert his power Kim jong-il was not
particularly liked by North Koreans they
officially feared him and so on but he
was not in and but that but there was a
whole generation that did genuinely have
some affection for kim il-song and kim
jong-un has very very much consciously
modelled himself on his grandfather and
he's been made to look like his
grandfather Kim song he stands like him
he just stick you lates like him the
Paramount goal for the leadership of
North Korea is regime survival
Hyundai XI honey she adoration an
extreme reverence of this kind relies on
the regime being strong and the
development of nuclear weapons was one
way of doing that
North Korea carried out its first
nuclear test in October 2006 John
Everard was the British ambassador to
North Korea at the time he only found
out about the test by accident by Shifu
the North Koreans detonated their device
on the day that the German embassy in
Pyongyang was holding their party to
celebrate German national day Germany
defendants day on a whim I thought I'll
just see what the news is and locked up
the BBC and there to my horror I saw
that North Korea had actually while we
had been sitting downstairs had exploded
a nuclear bomb so I printed out the
report handed it to the German
ambassador and I could see his face
freeze I mean he simply leant across to
the Vice Minister and couldn't make out
the words was to say something like what
on earth do you think you're playing at
here this was the start of a new period
of global instability what they were
trying to do was to protect the regime
to make themselves strong enough to
stand up what they perceived to be the
u.s. hostile policy and possibly to be
able to get into negotiations from a
position of strength what they hate is
the suggestion that they are weak or in
some ways a minor state they have a
great sense of pride
successive US presidents tried to
negotiate or threaten North Korea into
submission
none successful Bill Clinton came
closest but ultimately North Korea
always chose its nuclear ambitions over
any deal with the West if you look at it
from their point of view they see all
these exercises going on on their border
using strategic assets you see nuclear
bombers appearing you see submarines
appearing you see battle groups
appearing so I think their problem is
that they may see these facts which we
see in a particular way we see as
non-threatening they see them as was
genuine threats under Kim jong-un North
Korea hasn't just existed it is advanced
his historic step across the border and
into the South only happened because he
feels strong that he only feels strong
because his country is now a nuclear
power kim jeong-hoon is about to achieve
what his father and grandfather wanted
but never got a face-to-face meeting
with a sitting US president
[Music]
could this then be a turning point in
history a moment for North Korea to come
out into the open or will Kim jong-un
retreat back into the darkness once
again shut the doors on the outside
world
[Music]
you
[Music]